افتتاحيه صحيفتها ارتس قالت ان الحرب التي
شنتها اسرائيل ضد حماس لم تقترب من تحقيق
اي من الهدفين الذين حددتهما الحكومه على
الرغم من مرور 100 يوم فلا هي قضت على
حماس ولا حررت الرهائن وتبعت الصحيفه تقول
ان اصرار الحكومه على خيار الاستمرار في
القتال من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق لا يبدو
انه ينجح في الواقع اما صحيفه النيويورك
تايمز فكتبت ان نتنياهو استخدم نبره
التحدي في خطابه بعد 100 يوم من الحرب في
غزه رغم تزايد الشكوك بشان النتائج
المحققه وتزايد القلق الدولي بشان عدد
الوفيات في غزه وتزايد المخاوف من تحول
الحرب الى صراع اقليمي اوسع وتلاحظ
الصحيفه من خلال تصريحات نتنياهو وتعليقات
قياده الجيش ان الفجوه تتسع بين التصور
الاسرائيلي للحرب ونظره المجتمع الدولي
للازمه الانسانيه المتفاقم في غزه في
مووقع اكسيوس نقرا عن احباط متزايد داخل
البيت الابيض تجاه نتنياهو بسبب رفضه معظم
الطلبات التي تقدمت بها الاداره الامريكيه
بشان الحرب في غزه وتعتبر اولويه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده حسب الموقع يتركز القلق
الامريكي على امكانيه عدم التزام اسرائيل
بجدول زمني لخفض كثافه العمليات العسكريه
في غزه حينها سيكون من الصعب على بايدن
الحفاظ على على مستوى الدعم الحالي للحمله
العسكريه
الاسرائيليه حرب غزه تجدد الانطباع السيء
عن الولايات المتحده في العالم العربي هذا
ما نجده في مقال بموقع ذا هيل يرى ان
الدعم العسكري الامريكي العنيد كما يصفه
للغزو الاسرائيلي لغزه يؤجج المشاعر
المعاديه للولايات المتحده في الشارع
العربي ويعزز المقارنات بالغزو الامريكي
للعراق في عام 2003 ويضيف المقال انها
نتيجه لدعم اداره بايدن لحكومه نتنياهو
المتشدده صحيفه الجارديان نشرت تقريرا
تحدث عن نمط جديد من الاغتيالات
الاسرائيليه لقاده حزب الله يهدد
بالابتعاد عن قاعده تقليديه في اداره
الصراع تعتبر الاهداف العسكريه مقبوله
فبالنسبه لحزب الله قد يشكل استهداف
القاده الذين لا يمكن تعويضهم بسهوله
تحديا كبيرا جاء في التقرير نقلا عن
دبلوماسيين ان الاغتيالات
تهدد بتصعيد خطير وامكانيه انهيار الوفاق
الهش بين اسرائيل وحزب
الله